My naturopath is recommended managing my groin pain by using steroids. It is not her preferred method, but nothing else has worked in eight months and unceasing pain is left being debilitated and worn out and unable to function in the day and unable to sleep at night.
Is it safe to try steroids with bladder cancer and with a low dose of either dexamethasone or hydrocorrosone will be suitable?
Well, I can't tell you about the dose, but I do agree with your naturopath. So if a person cannot overcome their symptoms through natural leads and their symptoms are debilitated, that's what medication steps in.
So don't be afraid of doing medication. Do eat chemotherapy when it's appropriate. Do eat aerobaticia inhibitor when it's appropriate.
Using natural pain or using medical medication, pain medication when it's appropriate. Just do things when it's appropriate. If you give it eight months, it's a pretty fair shake of doing everything you possibly can to overcome your pain. If you're not sleeping, you're not going to have a good immune system.
You're going to have a much more difficult time to overcome your disease if you don't get your sleep and you're in constant pain. So I would say yes.
The doctor talked to your medical doctor about the dosage of the friend of his own. Of course, just mention to your doctor and you want to start with the lowest dose.
Hopefully, they're willing to work with you whenever you need to.
From the chat, my last MRI is showing the following, right? Retro, oral lymph node, structure measuring point seven is noted. What is this means and where is this?
Yeah. So, and they comparing to a previous, if you can just send me the MRI and then maybe schedule a time to talk, that would be the best thing to do.
Hopefully, this is a comparison to a previous one of the college or the radiologist should have done that if so as well.
Would you use a nebulizer for hydrogen peroxide? Yep, that's, that's what I said. You use nebulized hydrogen peroxide. What is the dosage and how often?
The dosage is on the home page of the member site. There's a recipe for nebulizing hydrogen peroxide. It's a Dr. Marcola document. You have to follow that recipe.
Exactly. To water down the hydrogen peroxide to the percent that you want to use in a nebulizer. So, how do you dilute the hydrogen peroxide? Follow that recipe and you make your make your solution following that recipe.
Put it in a little squirt bottle and then make enough so that you could use it for a week and you can do it several times a day. So, you can nebulize that solution that you've created following that recipe.
That's on the member site, the home page of the member site. Follow that recipe, make your solution and then you can nebulize that two or three times a day. So, that's how you would do that.